noël se prépare de différentes manières
en france et dans certaines régions la
tradition reste fort thomas strasbourg
où l'ont célébré hier sainte-lucie
strasbourg organise également depuis
quelques années une véritable fois
d'avant noël ludovic fossard sylvain
gauthier reportage
ce qui est vraiment bien strasbourg
c'est que quand c'est noël c'est noël
guirlandes de lumières regard émerveillé
gaufres au sucre et vin chaud
il a ressemble à un voyage dans le sapin
du père noël avec en décoration le
christ kingdom eric comprenait le marché
de l'enfant jésus qui s'est installée là
il y à 424 ans et qui fait toujours
autour et b
c'est vraiment ce que l'on lit un joli
enfin pour les enfants tous les parents
pour pour tout le monde quoi
c'est vraiment joli je pense que nulle
part ailleurs on aura cette ambiance
ambiance de travail bien sûr pour les
père noël je travaille c'est du joli
travail mais surtout pour les
commerçants qui ont les armes pour les
commerçants ces boues lourdes
si on commence à 8h on finit à 20 heures
ça a aussi son charme
est ce que mon lait c'est vrai que les
clients sont très heureux de chez nous
joufflu refus et dynamique
voilà donc le visage de ce noël 94 qui
attire de plus en plus de visiteurs et
qui réveille les imaginations
exemple avec la célébration de la sainte
lucie tradition directement importé de
thaïlande est organisé par des
commerçants est motivée par noël
c'est une fête de commerce mais ça n'est
pas qu'une fête des commerces c'est la
fête des enfants c'est la fête de tous
ceux qui ont gardé une âme d'enfant
même en tant que commerçant on a le
droit d'avoir une âme d'enfant et de le
faire savoir
à cela vous ajoutez un père noël et son
village pour des enfants contents mais
sceptique
vous avez une capitale européenne
devenue capitale de noël avec un sapin
symbole de sa grandeur qui du haut de
ses 38 m contempler paraît-il toute
l'europe